last year the defense contractor
lockheed martin the biggest in the world
ordered top executives to a three-day
virtual training to quote deconstruct
their white male culture
and unlearn their white male privilege
amazingly
a total of 13 lockheed employees obeyed
they went to the training like the bad
little girls they are
that would include the vice president in
charge of production of the f-35
fighter jet program who obviously has no
dignity and a retired three-star general
who doesn't either
chris ruffo is a senior fellow at the
manhattan and student contributor to
city journal he broke this story he
joins us now to tell us what this
training session was like chris thanks
so much
for coming on and for your reporting
what went on at this thing
well this is a long-standing training
program actually 8 000 lockheed martin
executives and employees have been
through race re-education programs
and this one was a particularly galling
they had these executives go through
these exercises where they said that
being a white male was analogous to
being a kkk member
uh to being in the aryan nation uh they
also said that uh you know
kind of funny way white men can't jump
and all of these
slurs and stereotypes about their own
origins and
they take it through a series of
exercises where they had to review 156
white male privileged statements
apologizing for their race apologizing
for their sex
apologizing for their orientation and
the question is this
if a three-star general retired in the
united states military
can't stand up to a bunch of crackpot
diversity trainers how on earth are we
going to stand up
to communist china well that's of course
that's right
where's your dignity you're an american
citizen you should never allow someone
to talk to you that way and they sat
there
like obedient castratos let me ask
this company wouldn't exist without
federal contracts they get billions of
course from the congress every year
congress is pretending this stuff isn't
happening is anyone in the congress
going to put a stop to this do you think
yeah i hope so you know lockheed martin
has tens of billions of dollars a year
coming from taxpayers
i want to know how many programs that
explicitly denigrate a white males has
lockheed parton done
has taxpayer dollars been used and you
know i'd call right now on the united
states senate and the u.s house of
representatives to launch an immediate
inquiry
to answer these questions because the
truth is really simple taxpayers should
not be subsidizing
woke racism at america's largest
corporations
is there any response from lockheed
martin
when you ask them how could you justify
this
yeah lockheed responded today with a
statement that could only be described
as corporate gibberish
it was a series of meaningless buzzwords
and statements
i think what's happened is that they've
been caught and internally they're
probably scrambling to figure out how to
respond because the documents that you
could see
on my twitter handle at my website are
absolutely damning
i'll make no bones about it this is a
neo-racist
program that's being forced on employees
and subsidized by the taxpayer
why are the only journalists doing these
stories
it's a good question you know that gives
me an advantage this is my beat that i'm
covering but
i think it's part of it is that people
are scared to speak out on these issues
these are issues of race and culture
that are the most sensitive
in our country and it's just going to
take more people that have the courage
to stand up
and speak out and to say racism is wrong
no matter where it comes from
and who it's directed towards that
should be simple but
in our country today it's a very scary
proposition for too many people
i hope that changes i almost want to say
that adult men who put up with this
deserve it i mean who would put up with
that for a
second you'd really have to have no
self-respect whatsoever but i
still think it should be stopped and i
appreciate what you're doing to shine a
light on it chris ruffo thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else